just the bread okay how do they do that
so for those of you don't know bakery
culture is really huge in Taiwan and I
was fortunate enough to live in an area
where a lot of these Taiwanese bakeries
found their way to where I live in
California so I decided to take some of
my favorite pastries and just share them
with my coworkers
so the first one that I have is a LUN
Manian Bao that basically just means
blueberry bun it usually has a really
delicious cream cheese blueberry filling
I usually don't get this just because
it's so dense but I'm really excited to
share this with one of my friends I
can't compare it to anything does this
make you feel like a happy Asian baby
mm-hmm so this is a real cochise's and
Gamble it literally just means a hotdog
cheese bread oh good yeah I would
definitely have to like work out yeah if
I eat that every day which I probably
wouldn't have a problem with if I could
have that like I would work out yeah and
then I would eat it it would defeat the
whole purpose of working out but I would
still feel I don't know about my life it
would be used to eat this when you were
kid yeah all the time
cool so when's the next time you're
going home so this is called a home
domion bah that means red bean bun I
grew up eating American food like
McDonald's so the idea of having beans
involved in a dessert sweet thing was
absolutely revolting to me in the
beginning but I've really grown to love
it mmm I'm usually so concerned whenever
I bring people to eat this stuff they
might think it's gross or the texture is
kind of weird red bean how's it going on
was there ever a point where where you
first thought you were like I don't know
about this I don't think so
cuz at least in dim sum like it's fried
so like you know we're American anything
that's fried like it's going down okay
last but certainly not least a palapa
kind of translates into a pineapple bun
but they kind of call it that simply
because the diamonds and the ridges on
here it actually looks like a pineapple
mmm-hmm good this actually tastes a lot
like a sticky bun that you get in
England but like they usually have icing
on top I measure between like sweet
bread and like a cross on almost that's
kind of how I try to explain it to
people sometimes is like
I call it like a Danish almost yeah I'm
glad you like it thank you for showing
me thank you well thank you yeah I'm
glad you shared this with me let's just
get this out there or Asian bakeries are
the best bakeries yes they are right
insurance you want to buy it
you're a different man you